eh bien vous chers amis comment
allez-vous nous ça va extrêmement bien
nous allons là oui celle-là c'est trop
bizarre qu'ils soient là bas les amis
nous sommes réunis aujourd'hui car il
n'y a pas longtemps au nord le super
téléphone non à la vidéo la haye
l'espace et on est passé devant un
magasin de jouets qui s'appelle à
melesse et un magasin de jouets pour
enfant sur six étages c'était génial ce
moment dans le magasin on a eu l'idée de
concept à chacun sa petite ardoise voilà
aujourd'hui nous allons à tour de rôle
présenter un jouet tu fumes en plein de
vidéos
ouais c'est interdit s'il faut oui le
but est de présenter les meilleurs
jouets et d'avoir les meilleures notes
tout simplement à la fin de la vidéo on
fera la moyenne de toutes les notes de
chacun celui qu'on a la meilleure note a
gagné la vidéo mais c'est pas tout on
invitera les gens à voter sur un sondage
twitter sur mon compte twitter on a
envie de savoir qui a gagné selon des
gens n'est ce pas donc on va aussi
n'oublie pas il faut qu'on ait envie
d'acheter ton jouet à la fin donc c'est
un jouet qui nécessite un petit peu de
préparation avant de vous présenter dans
sa globalité
je vous demander de vous occuper en
décidant par exemple des étoiles
bon au très joli neutre et les quais
deux styles différents préfets à
laquelle moi j'aime beaucoup ce fut tout
cas on dirait le carré du drapeau de
l'amérique tandis que j'adore aussi
celui de ne pas le passer il sait quand
le masque celle contre gardent bon qui
n'a jamais rêvé d'être un jedi
personnellement j'adore star wars il ya
quelque chose dans star wars qui m'a
beaucoup plu c'est le concept de force
je pense à lui je suis emploi je tombe
au sol le sabre éloigne toi de s'apprête
à vouloir moi je peux admettre que ce
soit mais là tu as besoin de la france
pour la btk en fait on utilisant la
force pour mettre la bêtise et la voix
attendons et la main qui tablaient sur
israël
ostrom verra bien
[Musique]
la force à se maîtriser ce qui
m'inquiète c'est des choses
bon voilà c'est un peu nouveau pour
vaincre il est maintenant temps chers
amis de noter cette session plus tu as
envie de l'acheter coutume une bonne
note
voilà j'ai fait a été super convaincant
mais sachez que c'est qu'une question de
temps yann gagnant j'ai pas eu assez de
temps pour bien maîtriser nager
ah ouais ça on a beaucoup aimé battre ou
taux d'investissement devrait dans la
présentation de cet objet au sepa en
cours messieurs dames
oui pas aux bonnes prestations monsieur
free merci c'était très sympa je suis
moi même un grand adepte de la force qui
n'a jamais rêvé de voir annuel faux dans
l'ancien on a déjà vu j'ai vécu une
expérience du fo c'est vrai ouais t'as
fait quoi
j'étais sur une plage du nau bassin
d'arcachon je peux présenter mon cheval
a pendant ceci est un faux et il vole
grâce à la force se dire qu a eu lieu au
29 line object là pour le coup on sait
ce que c'est l'espagne a fondu c'est un
truc en aluminium attendant l'étude sont
à 8,1 les saisies je vais pas faire
voler c'est faux tél monsieur free à des
responsables dans sa main ce que vous
voyez cette soucoupe volante est bonne
c'est bon ok donc cette seconde un peu
volet de cette manière
la récupère et sert à quoi le crime du
pont nomba diane et avant qu'un fils
voulait refaire la refermer les bien sûr
je pars en scoot ottaway c'est ce matin
mais quand réveillant ça me fait du mal
de gens
s
moi kato a alors caressé dans le sens où
si mon sabre laser très similaire est à
13 le fo a au moins l'audace de tourner
deux un peu plus d'éthique que à eva les
gars je m'en sors avec un petit con et
demi de moyenne pour le moment c'est pas
trop dégueu sort voilà on avance je ne
peux pas ok ok ok ça va max max touron
c'est carrément ce que c'est ton jeu du
coup oui allez bien représentés imaginez
vous attendre mais trop de tapage peu
importe la raison pour laquelle au delà
si c'est juste parce que vous avez vécu
là où je suis c'est pour des études je
vous invite à un quartier très chouette
en arrondissements 15e ya le 11e
vous êtes dans le métro bah vous êtes
vous êtes assis vous avez s'être une
place et là quelques entre est cette
personne
elle joue de l'accordéon
[Musique]
après c'est comme danser de déjouer à
merde attend un changement c'est un truc
mais les gars ont été la presta aussi
mise à part dont la tendance proche de 6
si son genou c'est un animal non mais
qu'est ce que tu fais celle de test pour
seb fais nous rêver
est ce que vous n'avez jamais rêvé oui
de pouvoir changer de voir pratique de
pouvoir peut-être bien chanter de
pouvoir modifier sa voix dans la vraie
vie
là on peut agir directement sous ses
propres records de calme avec le vibrato
le vibrato vient se placer sur des
complots cas ok donc ta de mode
pourquoi ça ressemble un sextoy seriez
tous les faire brûler en force le
vidéomaton veille aux différents
hôpitaux etc c'est basique et bonjour je
m'appelle sébastien normal son vibrato
avec le du bateau bonjour je m'appelle
sébastien je m'appelle c'est la science
et le vibrato qui marche
tesla deux candidats
c'est loupé plus draps jeu pour
sébastien bourque à sa charge de manière
de parler mexique ou pas je suis mac
sort ce vraiment la voix plus aiguë mon
bureau c'est trop bizarre je peux
essayer de le faire du tour dont il n'a
pas trop envie de laisser cei
le tajine ben oui c'est lucas bonjour
vous allez bien ça change de mains moi
les mecs
yes ok 18 et nous sommes six à dix huit
et demi vous savez pas chanter n'hésitez
pas juste fait en sorte que votre mère
ne le voit pas mais on a tous fait face
à un problème dans la vie à savoir
déclarer son amour à une femme 706 au
sérieux aujourd'hui j'ai un moyen simple
et efficace pour vous de déclarer votre
flamme
ça s'appelle le bim bam et je parle pas
des plats coréens les amis la fille
arrive chez soi avant qu'elles arrivent
faut prendre soin d'éteindre toutes les
lumières quoi ces traitements de
confiance et la fille arrive voulait dit
écoutez un truc j'ai arrêté depuis
longtemps mais j'aime cette année fait
je focalise vite faut que dali le jt m
elle est sur votre chat vous pouvez
arrêter de jouer en racheter un car il
est cassé et l'embrassé c'est bon c'est
bon tu fais bien je suis convaincu donc
on est d'accord tu connais pas une fille
tu proposerait de venir chez toi et tu
éteins la lumière sur le thème fois à
voir autre situation
ok tu as fait une grosse bêtise sauces
pâtes excusé c'est dur d'aller la voir
et lui dire écoute je suis désolé alors
elles rentrent à l'appart soir tu
l'attends comme ça face à la porte
d'entrée
et quand il arrive qu est ce que tu fais
les réseaux bien commencé par donner en
velay soulès repensé à tout ce que ça
implique se jouer à tous les coeurs
qu'il est possible de sauver à tous les
non dits qu'il est possible de dire à
tout l'amour qu'il est possible
d'envoyer grâce à cet outil
je vais fermer les stores
or c'est bien je suis content les gars
vous avez des gentils t'avoue que tu as
porté sur ta sauver c'était
excessivement longs mais mais tu as su
trouver des arguments couler même si le
bon on n'y croit pas trop si le genre
pour moi un truc qui montre une fois en
soirée je pensais tu t'amuses de seconde
avec quoi je panique et toi c'est pas
parce que j'ai montré qu'une seule fois
en soirée comme tout le monde
non mais tu comprends ce que je veux
dire on va être dans la vie de tous les
jours tu présente qu'une fois quelqu'un
voit la situati tu nous en reparlons
dire un bar ou si on va dire oui
maintenant je martin autrement et tu
seras surpris il ya moi je fais vrai
aussi j'ai une vraie question réelle tu
peux mettre combien de caractère après
6,7
ils connaissent par coeur et a répondu m
ses quatre fils d à 3 qu'est ce que tu
fais max en tentant un accord encore là
toujours c'est moi je veux faire un
sketch faisait les yeux doux
ces brouilles et du vent gens venus mais
pourquoi tu es sur mon bras tombera car
je suis dit est ce que tu veux vraiment
aller attaquer d'autres gens sa méthode
mais nestor juste de frapper non je me
sens bien c'est pas genre je te frappe
et but de bafé gomis bafé seront pas
notées à m'adapter mais c'était cool on
va donner là s'est vu du tout c'est trop
bas âge explosé à merde à noter ça va
trop regarder je fais un truc c'est de
l'impro j'agonise rare dans de terribles
souffrances je suis une autruche merde t
il aux mains yes
allez on note sa souplesse et sa rapide
allaient se plaît dans les espérances y
suis incapable ou dit non non c'est pas
que ça viendra pas dans le mirror
on peut vraiment parler un peu des
matches secs les jours voilà pour les
gens je veux dire je suis youtuber
humour quand cette barre
je me sens pas humoriste qui attaquait
toujours sans comédiens chanteurs mc
inquiète tout est cool toujours que je
me fasse rire mais moi je sais pas ça
mais c'était sans compter sur eric ce
soit vraiment ce qu'il ya c'est que ça
va non mais bien sûr
ça fait 17 ans tous ces supers alors bon
on t'explique nos choix
max veut dire juste pourquoi maxence
inquiète pas pour ça parce qu'on restait
tendue non vraiment moi seul alors ne
faisons comme l'abbé marrec c'est pas
hasard qu'un max martin et où il a fallu
faire coucher avec moi je ne sais pas
bien que ma personne qui souhaiterait
annuler ce tuning et discrétion vis je
le sais si je refais le mais ça ne fait
pas rire fait vite fait juste soyons
honnêtes talent par les nommer attenton
mais laisse tout parler c'est juste un
nouvel atout mais on peut pas donner je
vous laisse pa nou par la jeunesse doit
aller au bout bon tu veux expliquer
devant la mamelle femme appelle pas pour
faire des vidéos ont déjoué on est censé
drôle déjà c'est déjà moi j'ai malka
12h07 ces sept cas me disent des gens
n'y avait rien juste ans est pas du tout
et mon ton monte vite et on s'est même
battu tenable je vous des moments de
folie grosse juste à regarder et à pâtes
et papiers en vie alors caressé saoudite
selon max est un peu fou
maxence les amis c'est la fin de ce
concours de jouer alors à vue de nez
comme ça j'ai pas fait les calculs mais
je dirais que ma les jambières il a
étonné tout le monde avec ce dernier
jouet c'était la révélation la surprise
de la journée
seb je pense que tu es deuxième de ce
grand concours
il se trouve que je suis dernier mais ce
n'est pas grave je veux savoir c'est
qu'à gagner le coeur des gens alors les
gens vous allez cliquer sur un lien dans
la description
ça va vous ça va nous amener sur un
sondage twitter et vous allez voter les
mecs
merci est venu c'est cette hausse nous
nous jetterons qui fait ce n'est pas
passé par la chaîne de seine hésitez pas
à passer par la chaîne de maxence on
termine sur une magnifique chanson
dehors maxence
[Musique]